[Music]
welcome back from Kyoto Japan the old
imperial capital for more than a
thousand years and an awfully awfully
pretty place
final preparations are underway about 25
miles from here in Osaka for tomorrow's
g20 summit of world leaders the
president will be there we'll be
interviewing him back in America though
the 2020 election will be the first
election in which children born after
9/11 will be able to vote which is
bewildering to those of us who lived
through it during last night's debate
congressman Tim Ryan of Ohio said it's
America's duty to keep fighting in
Afghanistan for some reason 18 years
after we toppled the Taliban that turned
out to be a mistake
tulsi gabbard the only veteran on stage
corrected him watch this tell the
parents of those two soldiers who were
just killed in Afghanistan what we just
have to be engaged as a soldier I will
tell you that answer is unacceptable we
have to bring our troops home from
Afghanistan we are in a place in
Afghanistan where we have lost so many
lives we've spent so much money money
that's coming out of every one of our
pockets money that should be going into
communities here at home meeting the
needs of the people here at home we are
no better off in Afghanistan today than
we were when this war began all obvious
points none of which you're allowed to
say out loud in Washington now they make
congresswoman Tulsi Gabbard seem like
basically an untouchable she is not
allowed to get the kind of coverage that
the rest of the Democratic candidates
get but the viewers loved it at the
debate gabbard's was the most searched
name online Tulsi Gabbard of Hawaii
joins us tonight
Aloha congresswoman Gabbard soccer so I
I couldn't help but notice and I'm sure
you don't want to play the victim in
this but that you had despite the fact
that you want a number of online polls
you had the most Google searches your
name after the debate you got some of
the fewest minutes to speak of any of
the ten candidates on stage and you were
the only one who was essentially
attacked personally by the moderators
why do you think that was look it shows
that there's a clear bias in place I
made the most of every minute that I had
wish I had the opportunity to have more
time to address these important issues
but I want to just point out something
from that clip that you played that I
think is really important where we hear
a lot of politicians say the same
argument that well we've got to stay
engaged in the world otherwise we'll be
isolationists as though the only way the
United States can engage with other
countries is by blowing them up or
strangling them with economic sanctions
by smashing them and trying to overthrow
their governments this is exactly what's
wrong with this whole premise in the
whole view with which too many
politicians too many leaders in this
country are viewing the United States
role in the world how about the United
States be a leader in the world work out
differences and and build relationships
with negotiations and diplomacy and
finding common interests and seeing how
we can work together so that we can stop
sending our men and women in uniform
into harm's way serving in missions that
do not serve the interests of the
American people that make our country
less safe and actually end up causing
more harm and more damage to the people
in the countries where we wage these
wasteful regime-change wars that's the
kind of change in leadership that I'm
seeing as president you just mentioned
sanctions you're not questioning the
ironclad bipartisan consensus in
Washington that sanctions against Iran
are morally righteous and can never be
withdrawn are you
I am absolutely I think this is one of
the things that is leading us closer and
closer to a war with Iran a war that
would be far more devastating than
anything that we saw in the war in Iraq
I served in Iraq in 2005 in a medical
unit and this was the height of the Iraq
war there were lots of American
casualties almost every day and I was
confronted with that high terrible human
cost of war a war with Iran would make
that war with Iraq look like a picnic
escalating these crippling sanctions
withdrawing from the Iran nuclear deal
designating Iran's military as a
terrorist organization something us
unprecedented and continuing to deploy
more and more US troops the neo cons and
the Trump administration and Saudi
Arabia and Netanyahu have created a
situation where it's going to be very
difficult for president Trump to avoid a
war with Iran they have built all the
building blocks placed the dynamite and
lit the fuse and it's going to be up to
Donald Trump and his leadership whether
or not he is going to cut that fuse and
say hey we need to get back on track and
put the interests of the American people
in our country first and avoid a war
with Iran get back into that Iran
nuclear agreement this is why the neocon
hate you more than anybody more than
anybody they're writing pieces about you
right now but you know why wouldn't L
say yeah yeah nice to see you judges as
you pointed out really quick this is an
issue that conservatives Republicans
Democrats progressives this is a an
issue that transcends party lines and I
think that's where the leadership I
bring brings the opportunity to unify
the country to make this kind of change
that's important to every single
American in this country it's exactly
there's nothing partisan in the
slightest about this at all
exact and that's why it's such so nice
to hear someone say that out loud
congressman thank you very much thanks
Tucker